Would you take your child to a new age
convention where everyone was meditating
and trying to summon UFOs to abduct
them? How about to an occult ritual
where people were standing in a sigil
dressed in robes and chanting spells
trying to summon a demon? Then why would
you set your child in front of a movie
like Ilio that has that same message?
Okay, come and get me. Ooh, a new Disney
movie. I wonder what the plot is. Oh,
it's the same old story. Alien befriends
child. We've seen it over and over with
ALF, Mac and Me, Lilo and Stitch, Flight
of the Navigator, Iron Giant, and so
many other movies and shows. It's
nothing new. It's the same old plot,
only Ilio flips the script. It's no
longer about some innocent encounter,
but rather a child who goes out into a
field, lays on a sigil with the words,
"Aliens abduct me," and is summoning and
inviting nonhuman entities to abduct him
and take him away from home. M sounds
like a great story for